uh good afternoon uh welcome to the kby
center of Hillsdale College I'm Matthew
Spalding associate vice president Dean
uh here for Hillsdale College in
Washington
DC uh at Hillsdale College those of you
are familiar with us know that we
actually do believe America is an
exceptional
Nation uh this country's had a
discussion about exceptionalism for some
time now part of it because of the rise
in our politics of discussions about
America uh what has been lacking in that
discussion often is the source of that
exceptional
the substance behind the claim in a
debate over whether it is or is not uh
you need to have that substance to
respond to the arguments that American
claims of exceptionalism is merely
jingoism uh we have a great speaker to
talk about that topic uh today to talk
about how we should understand the
concept but also how we should talk
about exceptionalism in our politics uh
because that's very important uh as is
our tradition he's going to be
introduced today by a student of ours
currently on the Washington Hillsdale
internship program Bronte Wigan uh she's
from uh Montana she's a major in
politics a junior a minor in Spanish
part of the George Washington fellows
program uh on campus she is an RA
involved in students for life and she's
currently interning across the street uh
in the center for principles and
politics of the Heritage Foundation
Bronte well good afternoon and it's my
pleasure today to introduce Dr James
Caesar he is a professor of politics at
the University of Virginia and he's also
a senior fellow at the Hoover
institution he received his PhD from
Harvard University in government and he
has taught as a visiting professor at
Oxford Princeton and the University of
Florence he is also the author of
several books including reconstructing
America liberal democracy and political
science please welcome Dr James Caesar
thank
you
well thank you for the kind introduction
and uh nice to Welcome Matt over here
and on this side of Massachusetts
Avenue uh the United States Constitution
ratified some 225 years ago is
frequently referred to as our
foundational document because it sets
out the basic framework of our political
system the Constitution has of course
been changed and altered over its
history in 27 instances by formal
Amendment and in many other cases
through interpretation whether by the
courts exercising judicial review or by
political leaders working their will
through the political process but the
Constitution still stands and it retains
a good part of its original
character if it is asked why we hear
President Obama deploring almost daily
what he calls grid lock in Washington
because Congress sometimes thwarts what
he wishes to do and why his opponents in
Congress welcome this standoff regarding
it as a salutary check on executive
power again because it THS what
President Obama wishes to do the
underlying explanation is rooted in the
Constitution the very way in which the
Constitution ass signs and allots Powers
among the different institutions allows
if it does not encourage this kind of
Deadlock
the subject I wish to introduce this
afternoon is the Constitution and
American greatness now the diligent
pupil will always adhere strictly to the
assigned topic making certain to Define
carefully its key Concepts in terms
having spent a long career as a teacher
preaching Fidelity to this low but solid
standard and severely punishing any
student who dares to show the slightest
hint of
creativity I feel Duty bound this
afternoon to practice exactly what I
preach by the topic of the Constitution
and American greatness I should be
looking to see if there is a connection
between the Constitution and American
greatness merely to talk about the
Constitution and American greatness and
to assume that because these two things
may exist in the same place that they
are related that's
insufficient the Crux of the top topic
must be to show how the Constitution
call cuses or is the source of greatness
if it is I will eventually set the bar
even higher carrying diligence almost to
the point of
obsession and ask how the Constitution
by itself and not as a consequence of
any of its secondary effects directly
contributes to
Greatness but let me follow the uh
obligatory preliminaries and Define the
key
Concepts let's start with the
Constitution it's easy to characterize
the Constitution it refers to the
written text called the Constitution of
the United States that has some
4543 words it's comprised of the
original document ratified in 1789 and
its
amendments the words may be copied on
faux parchment for sale in souvenir
shops printed on paper and textbooks of
American politics or displayed as is
more often the case today an electronic
image replete with fancy hyperlinks none
of this matters it's the text that
counts all other questions that trouble
the audite especially law professors
such as whether the Constitution is
living dying or merely convalescing
these are issues of analysis not a basic
definition more challenging obviously is
to define the concept of national
greatness most discussions of greatness
focus on the individual person not the
nation on figure like George Washington
Abraham Lincoln Winston Churchill or
going back to Antiquity Alexander the
Great in Alexander's case and here you
could add Cyrus as well it's hard to be
ranked more highly on the scale of
greatness than to be given the epithet
the great to be attached to one's
name I mention that this is an epit in
memory of the embarrassing moment of a
UVA student who once asked in a public
lecture how it was that someone could
have the last name of the
great a number of Scholars have written
fine books on the subject of individual
greatness but do the qualities that
comprise greatness in an individual
resemble or shed light on the qualities
that Define greatness in a
collectivity many have heard of and
perhaps even had the occasion to look at
the nicoman ethics a book written by
Aristotle in that work Aristotle
provided what some consider to be the
classic portrait of individual greatness
which he presents under the imposing
title The Great sold man or the GSM for
short on first impression it seems that
some characteristics of this singular
creature have little to do with anything
that might be applied to a nation for
example the GSM is said to walk slowly
and to possess a deep voice yet Nations
do not walk on the other hand allowing a
little room for metaphor this
description of the GSM is in line with
Theodore Roosevelt's comment which he
thought should remain to American
greatness namely to speak softly and
carry a big
stick or again the GSM is described by
Aristotle as intent on bestowing favors
while always reluctant to accept them
this this strange kind of Pride might
seem initially out of place for a nation
though again second thoughts should be
entertained when President Putin last
fall so graciously stepped up to offer
his assistance to America in the matter
of resolving the problem of chemical
weapons in Syria was there not something
that detracted from our national
greatness in accepting the kind favor
and are we not now perhaps reaping the
Harvest of these seeds of supineness
that were sowed at this
time in fact it's surprising how much
our Founders thought could be learned
about National Greatness by studying
individuals James Madison in Federalist
62 reminds his readers that I quote one
nation is to another what one individual
is to
another he then proceeds to describe the
lamentable situation in which American
found itself under the government of the
Articles of
Confederation I quote she meaning
America finds that she is held in no
respect by her friends that she is the
derision of her
enemies words just like this one
suspects would be highly familiar to the
great sold
man getting out of this deplorable
situation also as Alexander tells his
readers in Federalist 11 will allow
America to dictate the terms of the
connection between the old and the new
world yes in this quote there is a
consideration of interest but the
language speaks more to the importance
of
Pride at the end of the day however
National greatness is a concept that
must be understood at least partially on
its own terms as a distinct phenomenon
and not entirely as an analog of
individual
greatness four characteristics I believe
captured the idea of national greatness
not all four are needed uh to for a
nation to be great perhaps just one will
suffice but here are the
four first a great nation will have the
means and power economic diplomatic and
especially military to impact other
nations in the world and the great
nation must use that power for what can
plausibly be described as a noble or com
commendable
end the power can be employed
defensively say to stop a conqueror bent
on crushing and enslaving other s like
the Spartans did at thermop I get that
from Reading uh seeing the movie
300 or power can be employed offensively
to build an Empire or hegemony like Rome
did in Antiquity or Great Britain did in
the 19th century from these Empires we
derive the latory terms Pax Romana and
Pax
britanica where are which are
celebrations of those Nations
greatness the great nation and I include
here a city state or Empire while it
will consider profit for itself though
it will sometimes be reluctant to admit
it thinks Beyond its own material
well-being and considers the interest of
the Empire as a whole or of the whole
world thus the great nation is
distinguished from say the Belgium
Empire which conquered just to plunder
the great nation conceives that the
world needs an order and that it is the
responsibility of the great for
greatness is characterized by assuming
responsibility to create and maintain
what is of General benefit a great
nation is not content to lead from
behind it wants to assume the mantle of
leading without complaining of
weariness second a great nation will
bestow a gift on the world a gift that
adds to the stock of goods that comprise
civilization Athens to this day is
renowned for what paricles proclaimed in
his uh funeral
oration you'll remember these words we
are lovers of beauty without
extravagance and lovers of wisdom
without
effeminacy other examples of Nations
that left the Legacy to civilization are
Rome which contributed so much to civil
law or the Dutch Republic which helped
build the modern system of Commerce and
trade these are cultural or scientific
or humanitarian gifts that provide
ornamentation to what it is to be
human now in the two characteristics of
greatness noted to this point it's
important to keep in mind the
distinction between good and great there
are nations that are good in the sense
of behaving like orderly and reliable
neighbors regularly so to speak taking
out their trash and cutting their lawns
some nation in today's world will pay
their United Nations dues on
time contribute on occasion to
International keeping for international
peacekeeping forces and vote
dutifully uh to uh limit the dangers of
climate change these nations do not
aspire to Greatness indeed many of them
argue rightly or wrongly that the world
would be better off without Nations that
aspire to Greatness it is the pushing
and jostling of the great for Honor they
say that leads to strife and
contention great Nations by contrast aim
for something
commendable admittedly a term of art
that's vague but still this at least is
clear great Nations talk about greatness
or to use an American synonym they talk
about
exceptionalism no one talks about
greatness in the duy of
Luxembourg no one extols exceptionalism
in
Bulgaria an American leader who most
frequently had a concern for greatness
though perhaps he took it beyond all
bonds of of proportion was Theodore
Roosevelt if Americans aimed as he said
to be a really great people they must
and I quote him again strive in good
faith to play a great part in the world
they must be capable of feeling that the
mighty lift the Thrills of stern men
with empires in their
brains it goes without saying that
Roosevelt's own words uh own words
perhaps uh on greatness perhaps go a
little bit too far he might think of his
own idea that greatness should speak
more
softly greatness also does not adhere to
a single pattern or formula it fits a
variety of forms and shapes it's hard to
say exactly what it consists of it can
be accompanied with significant flaws
but greatness aspires to be higher and
more noble even if the end it seeks does
not always bring all that's hoped
for third a great Nation plays a role in
shaping the destiny of the world a great
nation is commissioned to use hegelian
language to lead Humanity to its next
stage of development of
spirit in a different but related
account a great nation might be one
chosen by God to play a role in his
providential plan as John Milton wrote
of England in
Artica why else that this nation was
chosen before any other that out of her
as out of Zion should should be
proclaimed and sounded forth the first
Tidings and trumpet of the Reformation
of
Europe of course in this religious
context the language or term of
greatness would be avoided as it would
be suggest the human replacement for the
real source of power and greatness which
is the
almighty finally and here's a fourth
characteristic of greatness a great
nation is one that produces a new and
worthy mode of political
organization such a nation's Legacy is
found in its political order which it
bequeaths as a model for others to
admire and perhaps emulate In classical
times Sparta's Republican regime was
often singled out for praise and in the
18th century most admired England which
was the model regime for monu because
England protected the liberty of its
citizens now Americans often lay claim
to possessing National greatness and
most others in the world recognize this
too though sometimes
begrudgingly what is remarkable is that
Americans can stake a claim to Greatness
on the basis of all four of the
characteristics I noted first what of
power and power used for commendable
ends on The Ledger of defensive actions
America helped to save the
Constitutional democracies of Western
Europe from autocracy from Nazi conquest
and from communist
domination South Korea and Kuwait would
not exist today but for American might
and who can say what the fate of Israel
might be absent American power on The
Ledger of offense of action America has
shaped the social the security system of
the modern world order and has built the
world's Financial system America is not
an empire in the old sense seeking to
conquer and hold territory but neither
is it a nation like any other today
content just with living and letting
live it has been the indispensable
Nation many contend today that a large
part of America's political leadership
and an increasing number of its citizens
wish to renounce this role America is
dramatically cutting its military
spending and it has been treating its
dollar more and more like a local
currency than the world's Reserve
currency it is too early to say yet
whether these signs Mark a permanent
change of Direction and turn in America
away from greatness the current
Administration is known best for its
transformation of Affairs in the
domestic Arena but its most
consequential change has arguably been
in the area of Foreign Affairs where its
aim has been to make us act think and
feel like a nation that is just like all
other
nations again now by the standard of
culture or scientific accomplishment
America has made a tremendous gift to
civilization no I'm not referring here
to our pervasive popular culture of
dance and song and film which penetrates
into every corner of the globe the
verdict is still out on the depths of
these
contributions how will twerking
ultimately be judged in the cool light
of
History besides especially in song Some
of the greatest like Justin Bieber are
natives of other
countries but where America clearly has
made its singular and massive
contribution is in its innovation in
modes of
production and in the uses of technology
these accomplishments have led in the
past two centuries to a stunning rise in
the standard of living not only for
Americans but also for millions of
people throughout the
world again now by the Criterion of
promoting a mission America has played a
central role in shaping the destiny of
the modern world Hegel said as much and
toille proved it America wrote Hegel is
the land of the future where in the ages
that lie before us the burden of the
world's history shall reveal
itself it brought the idea of Rights
into the world and it proclaimed the
equal status of the Common
Man as for a religious Mission America
playing a part in sacred history
Scholars of American History we tell
will tell you that many Americans once
thought in these terms especially
especially the New England Puritans with
their Notions of building a city on a
hill many even today however cringe at
any such Notions which they regard as an
embarrassment to the nation and also to
Faith Perhaps it is on the other hand
when you think about it it's not beyond
the bounds of Faith or Reason to
consider whether there may be a special
role for this almost chosen people in
providing a safe haven for biblical
religion and in offering a modicum of
protection for those threatened and
persecuted around the world in its name
but let's not get sidetracked on matters
of
theology finally on that Criterion of
creating a worthy political model
America has staked its greatness on a
new form of government for the Modern
Age America offered as Abraham Lincoln
once put it something that held out a
great promise to all the people of the
world to to all time to
come the transformation in the form of
government that is taking place in so
many places around the world is a result
of the shot heard around the
world I love the encomium that James
Madison pronounced for the revolutionary
leaders in Federalist number 14 it is
enough to bring one to tears though I
confess to be one who gets a lump in his
throat at a ceremony for the opening of
a new shopping center still listen to
James Madison happily for America
happily we trust for the whole human
race they pursued a new and Noble course
they accomplished a revolution which had
no perils in the anals of human history
they reared the Fabrics of governments
which have no model on the face of the
globe obvious questions Loom today about
whether American could remain great
indeed about whether America wants to
remain great what many ask is so great
about greatness
greatness it is said is too costly too
burdensome or simply not
worthwhile on the one side of the
political Spectrum many see greatness as
an impediment to achieving the higher
goal of social justice or
equality on the other side of the
political Spectrum many think greatness
conflicts with the higher goal of
individuals enjoying fully their
individual rights for both of these
groups National greatness is a Fool's
errand
well let me not however wander too far
on the question of whether Americans
want greatness but return diligently to
the question of the connection between
the Constitution and greatness if as uh
as said America can rightly Proclaim its
greatness and if the Constitution forms
the basic framework of our government
then given the importance of government
to society it doesn't seem reasonable to
contend that the Constitution must
somehow be a precondition or cause cuse
of our greatness not only does this seem
to be a logical inference but in the
case of some of the characteristics I
discussed evidence can be adduced to
show that many of those involved in
creating the Constitution consciously
sought to create a nation that would be
powerful and creative that would alter
the destiny of the world and that would
provide humankind with the model of a
new form of
government yet at the same time however
intellectual rigor demands that we not
assign all causal power regarding
greatness to the
Constitution if the Constitution allows
for greatness it in no way mandates it
in all the respects mentioned if we look
at matters historically it's clear that
we would not have attained greatness in
the way that we have without deliberate
decisions taken by political actors
along the way and in almost every case
alternative paths were open and
advocated that would have led in a
different
direction in the early 19th century we
could have renounced ever becoming a
continental nation and clung to the
Eastern Sea Coast many preferred this in
the mid 19th century we could have
acquiesced to the division of the nation
into two countries an entire political
party was prepared to do so in the 20th
century we could have shied away from
ever becoming a military power able to
protect beyond our own continent
isolationists and pacifists pleaded
along these
lines all of these choices would have
been equally constitutional with the
steps that we did take we could abandon
greatness tomorrow and choose to be
ordinary we may be doing that just now
without violating anything in the
Constitution as for the gift of economic
transformation and technological
innovation it would be nice to believe
that the constitution was responsible
for the internet but everyone knows it
was created by Al Gore
nothing in the Constitution ever
demanded that we undertake the
collective mission of space exploration
John Kennedy decided to make it a
national project and he brought it
Americans around to embracing it in the
name of achieving the right stuff in a
clear renunciation of greatness we have
effectively abandoned the goal of
reaching Mars no one has alleged that
the that this decision is a violation of
the
Constitution as for our mission and
world history some cringe today even at
hearing at hearing the word Mission it
seems to have lost any command over the
imagination of our youth will we ever
again hear exceptionalism in this sense
praised in a presidential campaign Mr
Putin might not allow it yet for all
this our political system is no less in
perfect compliance with the
Constitution for these reasons and in
due diligence it cannot be said un
equivocally that the constitution has
caused American greatness in all the
areas surveyed so I accordingly propose
to take a slightly different path one
that shows how the Constitution almost
by itself including the act of Designing
and adopting it has contributed to
National greatness and pointed the way
to approaches to governing that have
been a model for the ages the
Constitution its conception production
and adoption stands as a monument of a
achievement in the theory and practice
of governance well what are the elements
of this case first the American
Constitution lend support to the idea
that governments can be made
successfully proving that governments
could be made or founded is the first
Criterion of significance or greatness
that's mentioned in the Federalist
Papers it is a theme that opens the
entire book and is found in a very
complex sentence written by Alexander
Hamilton I I'll read the the sentence
listen carefully because easy to lose
your way in it it is frequently it has
been frequently remarked that it seems
to have been reserved to the people of
this country by their conduct and
example to decide the important question
whether societies of men are really
capable or not of establishing good
government from reflection and choice or
whether they are forever destined to
depend for their political constitutions
on on accident and force not exactly a
sentence by
Hemingway now I used to think this
sentence was nothing more than a
complicated rhetorical flourish it
seemed to PO uh propose uh two holes or
pairs a government formed by reflection
and choice on the one hand and a
government that results from accident
and force on the other and then to say
that all good manifestly lies in the
first option that is of opting for
reflection in choice
and that all error lies in the second
that is being resigned to being
controlled by accident or
Force this evaluation I took to be
obvious accepted by anyone and in no
need of proof and yet in fact the
decision between these two pairs is not
so clear an argument could be made that
force is preferable to choice and
especially that accident is preferable
to
reflection the Constitution of the
United States becomes a focal point for
considering this theoretical question
whether good government is produced by
reflection rather than accident it turns
out was a central question of political
philosophy in the 18th and 19th
centuries the idea of making a
government from reflection as a product
of philosophy or science goes all the
way back to Plato in his Republic it was
embraced this idea by makavelli who
spoke of a new Prince in a new country
and more politely by Renee dear
who Pro proposed constructing
governments a new from plans derived
directly from reason as an architect
could plan for a house or an engineer
for a
bridge but a whole school of thought
beginning with monu and continuing with
hum and Burke grew up in opposition to
the wisdom of making and remaking
governments good government this school
said should instead grow by accretion
Edmund Burke is best known for this View
as he observed in speaking of his
beloved England which of course has no
written Constitution he said it was not
formed upon a regular plan or with any
Unity of design rather it developed in a
great length of time and by a great
variety of
accidents its parts he went on gradually
and almost insensibly accommodated
themselves to each
other putting this point in its most
emphatic terms Burke said the the very
idea of the fabrication of a new
government is enough to fill us with
disgust and
horror this almost natural process of
growth and accommodation through
accident is known in political thought
as the organic model of
constitutionalism now opponents of this
organic approach offered several reasons
in favor of their
position the act of making government
new has something about it of the
character of tyranny after all power is
radically centralized as the society is
remade or otherwise it could not be
remade the forces of restraint and limit
are ignored or destroyed furthermore the
example of remaking sets a precedent if
everything is remodeled or remade once
then there is no reason why it should
not be remodeled again just as one tears
down a building deemed Obsolete and
replaces it with something new and
better promoters of the US Constitution
presented the case for the possibility
of making or new modeling government as
they called it this is the starting
point of a theory of government that
flows directly from the United States
Constitution the Constitution was the
first real test for a nation of whether
remaking could be carried out
successfully modernity For Better or
Worse has been shaped by the American
example and yet while coming down on the
side of remaking the Constitution as
we'll see in a moment and its authors
represent a uni unique case inside this
category of remaking for the reason that
they sought to do the most possible
within a framework of making to take
account of the reasonable concern of
these organic
obors the second point in the theory of
government that attaches directly to the
Constitution is the concept of founding
or Founders or what is sometimes called
in political philosophy the legis Lor or
the lawgiver with capital
L's the founder represents the Pinnacle
of political greatness no other function
in politics enjoys the similar status a
prince or Statesman however brilliant
Works within the mold forged by the
founder the founder refers to one who
sets in motion the plan for a new order
who conceives or designs the plan this
could be the reflection part that
Hamilton is speaking of and who carries
that plan into execution
it goes without saying that a nation
established under the organic model does
not have a Founder in this sense Great
Britain has no founder indeed it is one
of the purposes of the organic Theory to
deny or at least to downplay the
function of founding
altogether many of those involved in
establishing the Constitution were
conscious of this function or office of
founding the Federalist in particular
Federalist 38 is one of the most
important Reflections in political
Theory on the theme of founding and
Founders this essay should be studied
along with the c classic treatments of
this theme which are found in mavelli
and rouso where there is discussions of
such figures as Moses and ramulus now in
Federalist 30 38 James Madison likewise
Sur surveys some of the great lawgivers
of antiquity including luris the founder
of Sparta and Sol and the founder of
Athenian
democracy the authors of the Federalists
by treating the subject were inviting a
comparison of America's Founders that is
themselves to these greatest of
political figures of the past and they
were offering themselves as models to
replace the
Ancients the existence of individuals of
such high rank in America is a paradox a
constitution that abolishes Rank and
nobility and that begins to establish
popular government is paired with a view
that suggests an expansive hierarchy in
the realm of our thought about
politics greatness is a concept that
asks the rest of us to look up to
something in this case to look up to the
founders the idea of Founders
underwrites the entire concept of
greatness in American
politics we are an egalitarian people
but a people that is supposed to look up
to something this notion is still
sufficiently powerful to supply on its
own a rebuke to those political pygs who
slight the Constitution like the
previous Speaker of the House of
Representatives or to the hotty
intellectuals like the Young Wood Wilson
who from ambition or Envy would replace
the
Constitution the only persons in the
world today who Merit the title of
successful lawgivers are the American
Founders others who have VI for this
status may have held it for a time but
they've all Fallen by the wayside in the
former Soviet Union the outside statues
of Lenin have mostly been torn down and
their Stone turned into dust Mao though
still formly credited does not supply
the model of China even Ataturk the
modern lawgiver who went so far in
transforming the habits and mores of the
Turkish people is now seeing his project
challenged and
undermined only one set of persons
enjoys the real status of Founders it is
the
Americans now third the Americans stand
as a monument of great because of the
way in which they made the
constitution elaborating on the way in
which the founding took place is one of
the founders main objects of reflection
in The Federalist Papers as Madison
noted we are to admire I quote the
improvements made by Americans on the
ancient mode of preparing and
establishing regular plans of
government the adoption of the new
constitution was by choice or consent
rather than
Force here was an important difference
between the American case and most of
the classical foundings the American
Founders were not like many of the
ancient Founders acting from a position
of complete Command able to compel
acception to the Constitution by
physical force or by the manipulation of
superstition the founders embraced this
limitation even as they acknowledged
that it took a toll on uh uh the wisdom
of the
Constitution the requirement that the
constitution had to be ratified by the
large body of the people is I would say
the decisive fact in the establishment
of popular government in the modern
world in all human Affairs the initial
example tends to be the most important
one which sets the precedent for all
that comes after I compare the American
case to the European one where various
versions of the European Constitution
have been submitted to referenda in a
number of countries including Denmark
France Ireland land and the Netherlands
where it has always been rejected never
mind the elites continue to build Europe
and even to pass a
constitution does that show you anything
about the spirit or manner in which
government takes place in
Europe the requirement of informed
consent for the Constitution introduced
another element into the distinct
character of the American
founding which different differentiates
it from the foundings of antiquity since
neither Force no Su Superstition could
be used America's Founders by necessity
had to employ a different form of
political discourse of course they used
rhetoric but the more striking fact in
studying the founding is the degree to
which rational argumentation became a
part of the exercise of ratification it
set a standard for political discussion
rarely adhered to but a standard
nonetheless the exercise of popular
choice or consent in the adoption of the
Constitution
is an event in the realm of practice
that has entered into an altered
political Theory one of the great
inventions of modern political theory
was the idea of the social contract
which is prominent in the thought of
John Lock and others the idea of the
contract was widely considered as the
juridical source of legitimate
government but this idea was always more
of an hypothesis than a
fact it was written about in books but
it never could be located literally in
history or practice ractice the use of
popular CH choice in adopting the
Constitution became in effect the first
concrete example of the social
contract this example has taken over the
hypothetical theory of the contract and
transformed it into an Institutional
reality the idea of adopting a
government by reflection rather than
allowing it to be formed by accident
open the door in politics to a new
intellectual Force reflection for the
authors of of the Constitution meant not
only a deliberation by the founders
among themselves but the introduction of
political science both in the form of
the observation and Analysis of the
effects of the operation of the State
Constitution and in the consultation of
great classic texts of political science
of the
age of course as the unending stream of
exercises in debunking the founders
inform us there was much political horse
trading and bargaining that went on at
the Constitutional
Convention we have barely recovered from
the shock of learning that the founders
were
politicians but the fact remains that
the main elements of structure in the
new government find their Source in the
science of Politics as the Federalist
and as a reading of Madison's personal
notes prove we would not have had the
American Constitution but with the study
of the texts of John Lock monu and David
Hume in other words we wouldn't have had
it without political
science here then is another Monument
set in motion by the
Constitution the writing of the
Constitution brought political science
down from the realm of theory and
transformed it into an active force in
shaping political life America's
government owes more to political
science than does any other nation and
political science owes more to American
constitutionalism than it does to any
other Nation the fate of America and of
political science are intertwined
this connection has one more chapter the
founders who made use of political
science also developed it the Federalist
is a major contribution to this science
the most significant so far produced in
America and one that now enjoys WID
spread respect alongside of the classics
of political Theory throughout the world
the Federalist and the Constitution
stand together as a pair the Twin Towers
of America's contribution to political
thought the most important important
point in the way that the constitution
was offered appears in a new instrument
namely a written
Constitution founding a new government
by the means of a written document is a
point now so widely accepted as to be
taken a second nature we have forgotten
the Innovation that it was in innovation
in this case that began in the American
states Thomas Jefferson pointed this
point this fact out Americans he said
were the first of the nations of the
earth which assembled its wise men
peacefully together to form a
fundamental Constitution to commit it to
writing and place it among their
archives archives where everyone should
be free to appeal to the text he was
referring in this case to the
establishment of the Virginia
Constitution proceeding by means of a
written
text was in one sense a necessity given
the prior idea of public consent the
public had to consent to something and
it was only by seeing that thing in
writing that people assembled in
different places and different times
could conduct the exercise of
ratification but the significance of a
written text immediate immediately went
far beyond the demands of the procedure
of
consent the written text fortified now
with the idea that it instantiated the
social contract became the highest power
standing above the government the
authority of government deres from the
Constitution and no office and no
official can exercise legitimate power
except in so far as it is consistent
with the
Constitution the teaching here is that
will is uh subordinate to
law the final point in the
Constitution's contribution to Modern
government is the founders theory of
keeping or maintaining the
Constitution it's not
self-evident that a constitution once
written can or should remain in effect
for a l period of time in fact the logic
of making a government almost suggests
the opposite why not repeat the exercise
in making when more is known and when
reason arrives at better
Solutions this was exactly the
conclusion drawn by Thomas Jefferson
when he called for a rewriting of the
Constitution every 19
years most of the founders took a
different View and pointed out the
dangers likely to result from such a
proposal their arguments are found
throughout the Federalist but most
notably in Federalist number 49 which
goes furthest in proving pointing out
the reasons for why the Constitution
should be maintained and also shows how
it would be
maintained the mechanism for maintaining
the Constitution rests on attaching to a
written document the idea of veneration
for a written text veneration supported
by the solemnity of the idea of founding
when one thinks about it it's no by no
means logical and it was by no means the
practice to connect reverence or
veneration to a written document even
today it would be a strange kind of
person who would profess R reverence for
say the constitution of
Illinois the dimension of reverence was
deliberately added as a way of
stabilizing the Constitution and helping
to ensure its
longevity it makes the Constitution into
something more than a paper or parchment
on which it's written the Constitution
comes to occupy the status of symbol of
the nation beyond the will of any
particular institution or
leader for this reason I chose upon
solemn reflection to place Federalist 49
on my license
plate by this means I hope to remind all
on the road especially the willful who
tailgate of the importance of fidelity
to the Constitution and even if someday
in the Far Far distant future the
Constitution like all things mortal
shall have ceased to be in effect the
license plate will by chance be
uncovered in some junk pile and serve to
remind people the Constitution as the
Monument of Americans greatness thank
[Applause]
you we have time for some questions uh
if You' raise your hands and we have two
microphones here as
well I start asking
questions yes
sir you mentioned that oh thank you
you're on the air
too you mentioned that great nations are
characterized by their use of power for
commendable ends hence uh the existence
uh of democratic Korea Kuwait Iraq um
these are all wars that America
Americans fought to uh ensure their
independence
but none of these wars were declared by
Congress per article one of the
Constitution is it problematic that we
pursue National greatness in spite of
the
Constitution yeah um leave Korea out for
a minute which is really a larger
problem than the other two I think we've
adopted a mechan mechanism which is tan
amount uh to to uh uh article one which
is uh uh was in effect both in Kuwait
and uh Iraq um let me say a word about
that I think really uh coming up to the
uh the war in Kuwait uh George Bush uh
the senior proposed the idea as many
others that the president could take the
nation into war by himself and insisted
that that was inherent in the powers of
the
executive uh Congress pushed back it was
especially angered the fact that uh the
the president might cite Authority from
the United Nations rather than from the
US Congress and a large uh uh battle Ure
ensued between the two branches on that
point and here's a a uh an important uh
s side point to make I don't think that
uh most constitutional issues are uh
decided by courts they're often decided
in the political process and such was
the case then I think the Constitutional
understanding that emerged was that uh
if you want to start a real war meaning
a war with a lot of troops moved a long
way uh away you have to have consent of
Congress uh I think that's where the
Constitution is today um I know we had
this this incident in Libya and uh
President Obama tried to get around it
one way or another but he did point out
this is not a real war in the sense of
committing American troops um in
subsequent uh instances Iraq and whatnot
you had to have the consent of Congress
to to begin those War Wars that's I
think is where the American Constitution
is today as you know there are a lot of
technical reasons why uh Declarations of
War have been shunned that make it a
little bit uh problematic but we have
something tantamount to it and something
very close to the spirit of the
Constitution I would say so final Point
don't always look to what the court says
for the Constitution look to settled
practice
um
uh thank you uh talk about the question
of the relationship between the
Constitution and American
greatness I was thinking of another
Constitution which was very very similar
to to the American Constitution the
smallest number of
differences um and it's the Confederate
Constitution which if you read turns out
to whole sections of it are just ripped
out of the US Constitution
with one major small difference and that
was the uh making slavery uh permanent
institution in the Confederate
States it strikes me that an awful lot
of uh what you said uh about the
American Constitution is very true a
great deal of it could be said or could
have been said ultimately about the
Confederate Constitution as well that is
suppose let's suppose that the Civil War
had been U successful from the point of
view of
Separation uh full consent could have
been could have been provided the people
who wrote the Constitution were not
inconsequential men interesting and good
Founders and a great deal would have
been
similar but there was one big big big
difference right and that is that the
one seems to be rooted the one is rooted
in principles of equality and Liberty
and the other is rooted in principle of
inequality
so the question I'm asking you is I I
found it kind of surprising that you
don't seem to have addressed what the
relationship is between the principles
say the principles of the Declaration of
Independence and American greatness
which seems to me to be seems to me at
any rate to be more important than
anything else including the Constitution
except in so far as the Constitution
embodies those principles in a
structure so well um I except point you
could say a little bit of the division
of labor maybe I assumed too much about
the importance of that it it is
interesting that the uh so so uh this
constitution without the the principles
uh on which it's founded would would be
uh a very different document and um who
knows whether it could have laid claim
to Greatness on its own without that um
and uh say this it's very interesting
you mentioned the parallels and there's
some differences between the US
Constitution and the constitution of the
Confederacy not only that when when it
was established at least afterwards uh
it was established on the the uh the
exact American model of founding as well
namely that you had to have a first
principal or as Alexander Stevens who
was the Vice President of the
Confederate said a Cornerstone or a
foundation which is what you were
referring to and he said the the problem
with the first Constitution which were
we're founding a government in the same
way starting with the foundation and
building a structure on top of it the
problem was that the
uh original founding was based on a
false Conner Cornerstone which was false
an understanding of science which was
false and only now have we come we argue
to a true understanding of uh of science
which is the principle of inequality of
the races so there was parallelism
throughout it's just that the parallel
in way mirror opposites but they they
approached the idea of governing in this
uh founding in the same way articulate a
Central Foundation and then a structure
which embodies that so um uh I I endorse
your your your comment and um almost
ashamed for not mentioning
it Jim thanks for a very nice talk I
appreciate it uh I want to go back to
the uh organic Constitution just for a
moment and get you to say again
concisely um or the what what counts
decis
against an organic constitution of
practice
and uh yeah I'm not sure I gr that was
the alternative to the idea that you
would remake you you were introducing it
in a very amable and well well sure
because yeah and now I want to but why
isn't it what counts against it right
that it just doesn't work or does it
have some the theoretical deficiency
yeah uh good point because in a way this
is a debate and it's very important in a
way for conservatives because a large
part of conservatism is grounded in
Edmond Burke and opposition to uh idea
of of making a remaking or founding
something new in fact you could say a
large part of conservatism was based
against the idea of a revolution we had
one and B redoing a government we did
that now of course in the minds of
conservatives the model that they had uh
to counter in the Practical
circumstances was uh France not the
United States the United States was
guilty of these sins only because of
France not vice versa uh some other
Burke and the others had to counter the
excesses of the French Revolution uh by
in a way uh offering an alternative view
well what about the American case what I
mentioned is the American case is a case
of making but it's a case of making
making that as you read uh the federals
papers you see it does almost all that's
possible to accommodate every credential
concern raised by the organic theorists
uh this is an instance of this is
maintaining a permanent written
Constitution the logic you could say of
remaking as I pointed out is probably to
keep remaking Jefferson in this way is a
a perfect example of the spirit of
remaking this is the thing that the or
the organic theorists were worried about
uh there's a lot of wisdom therefore in
the organic Model A final point to which
I I don't exactly subscribe but there's
some truth in it is to to say well when
you look back in it how much really did
the uh American Constitution
redo uh they thought they did a lot and
they did do a lot by establishing the
Constitution but put on a comparative
scale looked across other nations the
Constitution and what it sought to
remake was fairly limited and fairly
modest that is to say compare it with
the idea in France which you not only
establish a new government but tabular
Raza your intent and design is to
reformulate the entire character and
mores of the people not so of the
American Constitution um had important
but limited ends and in this sense many
people look back and say that America in
a way adopted and embraced huge parts of
the tradition that were already working
and built its models on certain
practices that already existed which is
to say it wasn't quite as inov ative as
um sometimes we like to say um so
there's something in that uh and I um I
meant to bring up the organic model uh
to keep it alive as an option uh and and
to show maybe that all truth doesn't lie
with one view or the other certainly in
my view the uh idea of remaking has
great dangers in it and if you remake
you have to do so in the most careful of
ways you have have to do the remaking as
I said that's most consistent with the
rational objections of the organic mode
of thought and I can't think of any uh
document or uh exercise that does this
better than the American
Constitution last
question U question about um what
constitutes greatness in the 19th
century America was great in many
respects without intervening in other
people's messes around the world uh in
the 20th century there was this theory
that there has to be some nation that
sort of maintains order and it has to be
America and so forth but what do you
think that the world would be like if
America did a lot less of that and and
and pulled back maybe not so much in
Europe and Japan but pulled back mainly
in the countries that don't seem to
appreciate it and would it still be what
what would the world be like without a
Pax America kind in your personal
opinion yeah well we're uh we're testing
that um and and there's something to be
said on both sides because you can
easily say that in this effort to uh say
have a kind of American Empire I put
Empire in quotes but a a kind of America
World Order uh that there have been uh
serious mistakes that have been made any
great Enterprise is going to have uh
errors as well as uh uh as well as
decisions that are helpful so it's a
question that has be raised it's been
the question debated especially inside
the academy uh for the last 50 years in
studying courses of international
relations and and whatnot this has in a
way been the issue would we be better
off if we hadn't uh assumed this role um
so the answer will come um um maybe if
we test this thoroughly you ask my own
view uh I I don't think the world can
exist peacefully without a uh an
overarching order so uh that's the
lesson I would draw from here history
that that won't work um that way behind
a successful World Order there has to be
a an Ultimate Force or a kind of
policeman policeman a gentle policeman
but a policeman who sets certain limits
that all recognize otherwise chaos will
be the result well what do I base this
on uh besides uh I suppose political
Prejudice and everything else I'm
usually accused of by my students and
whatnot
um I I uh look at certain historical
examples I not to point in the uh study
of the thus cities pelian Wars where for
a moment of time Athens and Sparta both
step back and you have this long boring
part of pipian Wars where it's uh pages
and pages of chaos all these little
nations are jumping on others fighting
each other that the World falls into
chaos without uh some sort of order um
that I think would be the result I think
as a result that uh we would have
established much more without British
power uh obviously um I can't prove this
to anyone I can only suggest this is the
case and as I said we may be testing
whether this is true um we haven't had a
long enough test uh um that has to be
said but um I don't know if you're
content with where you see certain
things going uh in a world without that
Force standing behind behind it that set
certain limits if that's where we're
going I think we maybe can begin to see
some of the um the dangers that are part
of that uh world
order thank
you